welcome back to CBS mornings baseball's
opening day is just a few weeks from now
and once again the Los Angeles Dodgers
are an early favorite to get to the
World Series they're led by their
Superstar right fielder that's Mookie
Betts the 30 year old is considered one
of the best hitters in the game he
already has two World Series rings and
baseball is only one of his passions
Eureka Duncan visited bets at his La
home to learn about his other favorite
game and his drive to give back
[Applause]
is known for setting teams on a
championship path
2018 with the Boston Red Sox bets became
the first player in major league history
to win the MVP Gold Glove Silver Slugger
and the World Series in the same season
two seasons later he won another world
series title this time with the Los
Angeles Dodgers you go into the World
Series this year
he has to plan every year that's the
plan every year it's always a tough
process though but uh it's fun but Betts
has another love where balls and Strikes
take on a new meaning
yeah
by his count he's bowled at least 30
perfect games
mookie in an LA bowling alley last month
he and his wife Brianna hosted their
first charity event right down the
middle I was my form honestly is
horrible but it's okay what would make
it better no it's not horrible it's not
horrible and he would know bowling is in
his blood his mother Diana Collins gave
birth to mookie just hours after playing
in a tournament
competitive Drive clearly runs in the
family
my family is very competitive I mean we
play marbles and we're trying to win
when mookie came along it was just par
for the course you have to learn to be
competitive we don't play with you I'm
nervous
tournament raised more than 120 thousand
dollars for children in underserved
communities I just want to provide the
opportunity for a kid's dream to come
true
where does the compassion come from in
this want to give back seeing my mom and
my dad and how
when I was going to football practice
when I was going to baseball games we
were always there early he would wash
other kids clothes he would make sure
that other kids were good the same way I
was good and my mom as well we were
paying for everybody's food and we were
doing these these type of things and so
I think it just kind of got instilled in
me mookie grew up in Nashville Tennessee
it's where he met his wife Brianna in
middle school he was like will you be my
girlfriend I didn't answer but I didn't
hear him honestly you mumbled yeah he
had to because like I didn't hear that I
would hear that how did it sound it's
like you were my girlfriend probably
yeah just like that yeah because I was
you know you're nervous
these days there
fore daughter Ken Lee is arguably the
real star of the family by the spring
she'll be a big sister
having our daughter really opened up my
eyes kids have endless dreams and hopes
and they never give up
his family also includes his childhood
friends who are always willing to team
up when mookie is ready to serve back in
2018 after bets won game two of the
World Series he and his friends were
spotted leaving food for the homeless we
all have the same
selflessness think about other people
before ourselves I don't do these things
for people's recognition I do it for me
and God doesn't need cameras no God sees
it and Beth sees himself as more than
just an athlete alongside his friends he
recently launched a production company
first release Jackie Robinson get to the
bag
you can't Embrace history ever the hate
that came with the winds was all
sticking together to the sounds of
hip-hop the story goes beyond baseball
to Mark the history Robinson made as the
first black executive of a National
Corporation and founder of a bank in
Harlem making loans more readily
available to black people the agendas
had in the tank and shot full of nuts to
Freedom National Bank LED some of mine
to call me an Uncle Tom capitalist
pardon me for giving you my advantages
and he's a huge huge influence if I
start to do something whatever it is I
go hard like I I am all my time because
I don't know how to half do anything
last year for the first time since
Robinson integrated pro ball in 1947
there wasn't a single African-American
player on the World Series roster That
season mookie wore a shirt that read we
need more black people at the stadium I
think the one of the main things is that
the kids don't see us out there you know
if you watch football and basketball you
can see us everywhere all on the court
all in the commercials I have to
continue to do my part getting ourselves
out there so kids can see someone that
they can they can beat on one hand
baseball brought him Fame on the other
bowling has offered balance and
is my happy place he spends hours in his
garage drilling or polishing his
collection of bowling balls so why do
you have so many I hoard them you know
Bowlers horde bowling balls this is
normal this is where it all goes down
after baseball games sometimes I come
out here a lot of ideas
come out of here so this is a very
special place in this house you want to
finish it yeah okay oh I can yeah why
training is it full swing and you can
bet mookie is ready to play ball
how have you been able to manage this
competitive nature this 100 and
everything you do but also give yourself
Grace to make mistakes nine pitch I
don't think I give myself Grace is that
something you're working on
no because it made me who I am
back support for the home run I'm not
perfect but I also strive to be perfect
and the closer I can get to perfect the
better I'll be
hmm
truly a phenomenal athlete 30 years old
wife 28 years old just a couple to watch
without a doubt now listen to this
though Mookie's mother and father
believed that their son was destined for
greatness that they named him Marcus
Lynn Betts so he'd have the initials
MLB or Major League Baseball and just to
give you guys a taste of what it's like
yeah Mookie Betts yes his chef at his
homemade cinnamon rolls while we were
there his Chef Mr Dalton James Dalton he
gave me the recipe okay
I made these to everybody
no Drake is a good cook I always like to
get the center
and get in there what can't you do
Eureka so they don't say exactly like Mr
Dalton's are you trying to put her on
sale so she doesn't slide me I know
right not exactly but you know I'm
trying to become a better cook so every
opportunity to do this with the story I
love it I will but really mookie bets
his wife his family
they were outstanding really really
looking I could not be bribed if you win
darika you're going down you're going
down